if you think rocket science sounds
difficult just wait until i tell you
about this company space ride
instead of just launching rockets from
the ground they use balloons to carry
rockets into the upper atmosphere before
launching them and surprisingly it
actually works at the center of this
project is this guy my name is sora
pagigat and i'm the founder and ceo of
space ride he's a super talented
engineer based in canada and he's been
building this company for the past five
years recently we've seen a bit of an
arms race to build bigger and bigger
rockets starship usually gets all of the
attention and for good reason it can
deliver a payload of a hundred metric
tons to low earth orbit space ride on
the other hand can only deliver about a
hundred kilos that's a thousand times
less but there's actually a very good
reason for this approach what i really
want to be able to do is to enable
small satellites and small payloads that
are going to space so they can achieve
their mission see the space industry is
growing so quickly now that there are
needs at both ends of the payload
spectrum starship and bigger rockets
will obviously be incredibly important
for huge payloads but the high price can
lock out smaller projects ride sharing
on spacex rockets will work for some
companies but you'll still need to deal
with the narrow launch schedules if
spacex is building a massive 18-wheeler
space ride is building a taxi service
it's highly customizable and incredibly
affordable so let's dig into how this
actually works spaceride combines three
main technologies to deliver payloads to
low earth orbit the first is the balloon
and this is by far the easiest part but
before we talk about how the balloon
works we need to answer the obvious
question of why you would even want to
use a balloon in the first place well
even though we don't notice it when
we're just walking around the atmosphere
is actually pretty thick down here on
earth all that air creates an incredible
amount of drag on a rocket while it's
taking off if you want to counteract
this drag you just need more power which
means a bigger rocket a bigger rocket of
course means even more drag this isn't a
problem for big rockets with big
payloads but if you're trying to deliver
smaller payloads you'll wind up wasting
lots of energy just plowing through the
first layer of earth's atmosphere
balloon is our cheat because it gives
you a free ride to the edge of the
atmosphere there is another benefit
though during every rocket launch at
some point you'll hear the ground crew
say we've reached max q we throttle the
engines down in preparation for max q or
maximum aerodynamic pressure this is the
largest structural load that the vehicle
sees during ascent so slowing the
vehicle down helps during that short
period what that means is that the
rocket has just reached the air pressure
limit due to the atmosphere and it needs
to throttle back when you launch a
balloon 30 kilometers above the ground
max q isn't an issue so you can design a
completely different rocket so rob and
his team have done just that but before
we dive into their rocket design let's
talk about the history of space balloons
now i don't know anyone who would watch
a balloon launch over a rocket launch
but they're actually an incredibly
important part of modern science nasa
alone launches a new mission every month
through their scientific balloon program
and balloons are so simple to make that
even high school students can launch
stuff into space using them balloons are
incredibly reliable at this point but
more importantly they are incredibly
cheap so the balloon as far as we care
about it is a commodity so we buy our
balloon the balloons they use are made
out of simple plastic materials not
unlike a shopping bag and they fill it
with hydrogen gas which provides plenty
of lift capacity and is extremely
affordable if you're ever looking at
prices of anything in the space industry
you'll be shocked to find anything
selling for less than a million dollars
even small parts on big rockets can be
extremely expensive and those prices get
passed through directly to launch costs
this is why even though the cost of
delivering payloads to space is falling
significantly on a per kilo basis
individual launches are still millions
of dollars in fact the cheapest rocket
on a per launch basis right now is
provided by astra and it's still around
3 million dollars but space ride will
offer launches for one-third that cost
and has plans to quickly push the price
below a million dollars per launch this
could be really disrupting at scale and
it's incredibly impressive for such a
small company after all astra has raised
hundreds of millions of dollars and is a
public company now space ride has raised
less than five million dollars so far
leveraging existing and reliable
technology is key to so many startup
success stories but the only reason
balloons are so widely accepted in the
aerospace industry is because they've
been in use for over a hundred years now
all the way back in 1912 an austrian
physicist named victor hess used a hot
air balloon to measure radiation levels
in the atmosphere at the time people
believed that radiation came from the
earth so the higher you went the lower
the radiation level would be but his
measurement showed that the radiation
levels actually increased at high
altitudes suggesting that the radiation
was coming from space he had essentially
discovered cosmic rays and he won the
nobel prize in physics for his worth
flash forward to 1949 and balloons again
played a critical role in atmospheric
research a group of american naval
scientists attached a rocket to a
balloon and launched it off of the uss
norton sound they called this rocket
balloon a raccoon and even though it did
successfully launch the rocket the fact
that they couldn't steer the contraption
really limited its usefulness but
spaceride has solved this problem with
their second key piece of technology the
rocket carrier rocket carrier is the key
ingredient of this business no one is
going to pay space ride to launch their
satellites into orbit if they can't
guarantee where it will wind up orbiting
a big part of the space ride value
proposition is that small satellite
companies can not only choose when to
launch but they can decide the exact
orbit that they want for their
satellites that type of customizability
is largely unattainable via larger
launch companies unless of course you're
willing to fork over the millions of
dollars it costs to cover the entire
launch the space ride rocket carrier
attaches the rocket to the balloon and
more importantly make sure that the
rocket is pointing in the right
direction when it launches the carrier
itself looks kind of like a quad rotor
drone but there are some really
important calculations going on to make
subtle corrections and make sure that
the rocket is aligned properly at launch
now air launches have been tried before
but they've never really made much
economic sense the most well-known
air-launched rocket is the northrop
grumman pegasus which has been in
operation since 1990. even though
pegasus has had a solid track record
over the last 30 years it still costs
over 40 million dollars per launch and
has a host of other problems back in
2012 elon musk actually addressed the
pegasus vehicle directly when you drop
the rocket your cell phone because
you're not going the right direction do
you see what uh say all the scientists
did with pegasus have the delta wing do
the turning turn maneuver and then
you've got this big wing which just
added a bunch of mounts the net is it's
not great you started off with the
things this has an air launch vehicle
and it subsequently did not do any air
launch vehicles simply put that delta
wing on top of the pegasus rocket is
inefficient but space ride doesn't need
one of those on their rocket because the
rocket carrier can position the rocket
automatically before it launches it's an
interesting situation where advances in
software lead to simpler hardware
solutions similar to how self-driving
cars have been able to move away from
complicated lidar systems and just use
normal cameras because of advances in
machine learning this is always a great
place to be in as a startup software is
getting better at a much faster rate
than hardware so anytime you can
leverage the cutting edge of software
development you have an advantage and
sorob knows this intimately before he
founded space ride he actually worked on
self-driving cars at cruise automation
while there he worked on planning and
controls which has a remarkable amount
of overlap with the work he's doing now
at space ride see every autonomous
vehicle has to do two things first it
has to perceive the world which
basically just means stitching together
all of the camera and sensor data into a
three-dimensional representation of the
world just like a video game then the
system has to decide what to do with
that data where to actually drive the
car safely which means planning out a
safe path and then sending inputs to the
steering wheel and gas pedal accordingly
so rob worked on that second part of
cruise and it's a perfect fit for space
ride the perception problem is a lot
simpler in a balloon since there are no
pedestrians to deal with up in the sky
unless of course you run into felix
baumgartner pulling a stunt for red bull
but controlling the rocket carrier is
remarkably similar to controlling a car
when the team goes to launch a balloon
they know the general trajectory and can
plan out a basic course of action but
once everything lifts off the autonomous
systems have to take over being able to
reliably steer the carrier without a
pilot is really tricky but doing this
with software means it's ultimately more
reliable and more affordable so once the
balloon is up there and the rocket
carrier is in the right position what
happens well they have to launch the
rocket but space ride rockets are custom
made to take advantage of the high
altitude when you look at rockets
they're often tall and slender there's a
reason because you're minimizing drag
there is no drag concern when you're
launching at 30 kilometer altitude so
your rocket can be short and chubby and
a fat rocket is actually a good rocket
this fat rocket is more than just funny
though it actually serves a very
specific purpose although the design is
unorthodox these space ride fat rockets
find the perfect balance between
structural integrity fuel efficiency and
payload capacity and this is super
critical because space ride is all about
unlocking the small payload delivery
market which is actually growing
incredibly quickly pretty much everyone
knows about starlink at this point but
global internet is far from the only
useful application for small satellites
increasingly satellites are getting
smaller and smaller all while becoming
more versatile and useful this can be
hard to visualize because when most of
us think about satellites we imagine the
hubble telescope or the international
space station you know the type of space
stuff that's actually big enough to
point a camera at but satellites are
getting small like really small
traditionally a small satellite is
defined as anything under 1 000
kilograms but space ride is only
planning on carrying between 80 and 150
kilograms that's not a problem though
because micro satellites or cubesats
typically weigh less than 100 kilograms
with some as light as just 10 kilos
there are also nano satellites now that
weigh under 10 kilos pico satellites
that weigh less than 1 kilo and people
are even prototyping femto satellites
that weigh less than 100 grams that's
remarkably light at that point it's
basically just a simple chip floating
around up there but as we've seen with
smartphones you can fit a lot on a
single chip these days so we have a few
technology trends all accelerating and
converging at the same time to make this
a reality demand for satellites is
increasing exponentially satellites are
getting smaller and smaller and
autonomous control software is getting
better all of these trends point to an
easy win for space ride right well not
so fast so rob has been working on this
for the past five years and i could tell
from my conversation with him that it
hasn't all been easy first off he's
doing all of this in canada which hasn't
had an active launch program in the
country for decades canada does have
astronauts but they partner with the
united states and european space agency
for actual launch capabilities
fortunately saurabh has an amazing
partner in his wife and co-founder
saharnas she has an mba and serves as
space ride's chief operating officer so
when it was time to work with the
canadian government to get regulatory
approval she stepped up and got it done
in record time often the best founding
teams have different but complementary
skill sets after all it doesn't matter
how well designed your rocket is if no
one will let you launch it but there's
one more key takeaway that i love from
this story and it's all about
determination so rob probably could have
coasted as an engineer in silicon valley
for his entire career cruz was a massive
success and he was there early but he
wanted to pursue something bigger we are
running out of resources on the planet
he really cares deeply about space and
what it can unlock for humanity broadly
lots of people aspire to work in
impactful industries when they're young
but then they get caught on a particular
treadmill and lose sight of their
original goal so rob took a lot of risk
by switching industries after leaving
crews he probably could have worked at
any self-driving car company but he
chose to pursue something bigger and he
didn't just risk a few resume bullet
points he actually took out a second
mortgage just to pay for space ride's
rocket testing facility no one would
rent him land to test rockets which
honestly is kind of understandable so he
just did it himself when you're working
at a big company enjoying free lunches
it can be hard to take a leap of faith
and go build something in a garage but
i'm certain that when sarab looks back
on his time building rockets in his
garage he won't regret one minute of it
if you want to chat about space just dm
me on twitter and please check out this
recommended video the youtube algorithm
thinks you'll really like it